c'est ce qu'on appelle donné de sa
personne ces trois commerçants de baume
les dames viennent défendre leur
enseigne dans le plus simple appareil
pour donner un peu de légèreté à cette
période assez maussade on avait déjà
fait une vidéo nous sommes sur notre
commerce qui était plutôt un peu morose
pour vous faire faire comprendre aux
gens la situation était grave
on se dit que maintenant tension n'a
plus rien à perdre donc du coup il faut
le prendre plus tôt avec le sourire même
si même si le futur nous dira si c'était
bien pas juste avant le shooting les
commerçants n'arrive pas les mains vides
ils ont pensé aux accessoires de
circonstance elle est à l'origine de ce
projet original
sophie petit j'en possède son studio de
photographie à baume-les-dames pour
défendre les commerçants de sa commune
elle les a tous contactés par mail un
succès quasi immédiat en deux jours déjà
une vingtaine d'entre eux se sont dits
prêts à participer à l'opération
là ça va vite parce que je pense que les
gens veulent faire ça tout de suite
parce qu'ils veulent vraiment entrés
dans le mouvement maintenant est ce qui
est très bien parce que je pense qu'il
faut pas que ça retombe
mais sincèrement j'étais sûr que ça
allait marcher j'en étais sûr ces genres
de choses qui marchent tout le temps on
a vu des commerçants dans d'autres
villes faire des calendriers où il était
nu ça a toujours cartonné toutes les
photos sont postés sur les réseaux
sociaux mais se fit petitjean ne
s'arrête pas là et veut voir plus grand
elle réfléchit à faire imprimer un
calendrier et pourquoi pas affiché une
banderole avec tous les clichés dans les
rues de là comme à oui ils vont être
déçus des clients si tu le fais pas